well with 11 million people listening
via podcast and radio to the show you
have to know that a certain percentage
of them are absolute morons I mean just
have lost their ever loving minds most
people are pretty nice and have their
sense about them and have good you know
good decorum and so forth I mean when we
do a millionaire themed hour we get
nothing but just absolute rave reviews
everyone loves me interviewing the
millionaire so you can learn how to be a
millionaire
for instance Kyle says Dave thanks for
the millionaire hour last week very
inspirational all presidential
candidates should be required to listen
to that but occasionally you have I
don't know someone whose parents are
cousins or something I don't know what
their deal is
but like Dan dan says dear Dave frankly
who gives a crap about these
millionaires of the three I heard all
were salesmen computer techs and
businesspeople now Dave I work in health
care my net worth is maybe 50 grand in
all my years in the emergency room I've
never heard hear anyone scream get me
Dave Ramsey or any of these salespeople
computer techs or salesmen I consider
you all glutens to society I think you
meant gluttons spelling thing it messes
you up in the ER doesn't it have a great
day money isn't everything so Dan you
should spend some of your income on
anger counseling you obviously have
extreme issues um and what I'm confused
about is why you listen to the show at
all see I've got a rule if stuff pisses
me off at the level that this is
obviously pissed you off
I just don't listen to it like I don't
listen to Hillary Clinton speeches they
just make me angry or Bernie Sanders
socialism speeches they just make me
angry you may feel that way about
somebody else that's fine well why do
you say I mean but I don't spend time I
don't follow Hillary on Twitter because
that would just make me mad like this
made you mad because my my view of my
worldview
is so completely different I believe in
capitalism I believe in the free
enterprise system
I believe the little man can get ahead I
really do believe that and I've got
statistical and antidotal proof of all
of those things and I will continue to
roll it out as if though you somehow are
superior to people that write books or
do radio shows or you're somehow
superior to salesmen or computer techs
because you work in healthcare you're
not superior you just work in an
industry like anybody else you're not
any better because of your chosen career
path as a matter of fact your lack of
manners and ability to actually string a
sentence together as an indicator you
have real issues going on you're far
from superior as a matter of fact you
would be inferior to all of these people
because they've actually chosen a
reasonable field have excelled in that
field over an extended period of time
and made twice what you've made an
average millionaire that we've
interviewed in these million are hours
is making around 125,000 over an average
of 20 25 years and most of them have two
to five million dollars not just one
million dollars and so how are they
gluttonous to society they're not Glens
to society they've done anything wrong
you're just a bitter screwed up trapped
individual that's all you are
so what I'll invite you to do is to
listen to something else go somewhere
else go away and by the way if you don't
like something I'm saying on the show
any of you at any time I invite you to
leave I'm fine with that we call this
the Dave Ramsey show for a reason not
only do I own it but it's my freakin
opinion about these things ten eleven
million people seem to care every day
what that opinion is if you don't that's
okay with me I can live with that I
don't agree with you Dave that's fine
leave it's okay I mean
you know it's just it's amazes me that
people like Dan think we care but here's
the problem with our culture that when
people like this are setting the tone of
the cultural marketplace
instead of sitting down and looking at
your children and saying honey you can
be anything you want to be in America
today you can study you can work and you
can study some more and you can work
some more and you can start from nothing
and be a millionaire eighty-eight
percent of America's millionaires are
first-generation rich that means they
started with nothing and they became
wealthy no money is not everything but
it is an indicator in those lives of
their particular discipline the
discipline they had in their lives the
excellence they had in their lives and
it shows their character now does it
mean that someone is poor can't have
good character doesn't mean that at all
of course you can be poor but there's a
high correlation between wealth building
and the ability to be diligent and
diligence is excellence over time
continually sowing and continually
reaping now there's different levels of
intelligence there's different levels of
talent there's different levels of work
ethic there's different levels of focus
and different levels of
stick-to-itiveness that's why there will
never be I hope I pray there will never
be income or wealth equality in America
I pray it never happens do you hear me
because if someone works twice as many
hours as someone else they should make
twice as much money wealth inequality
quality would be highly unfair if
someone is twice as smart as someone
else and can build a computer that's
twice as good as someone else can build
a computer they ought to make twice as
much it would be unfair for the people
don't work as much aren't as smart
aren't as talented don't bring as much
to the economy don't bring as many gifts
to you and I to use to make the same
amount of money if one music artist
sells 10,000 item albums and one sells
10,000,000 they should not get paid the
same
if you sell ten times as much you should
make ten times as much that's fair
equality because talents because work
ethic because intelligence even looks is
not distributed equally then one hundred
percent of time for things to for the
economy to be exactly equal there's
nothing you call that except communism
and it would not be fair by definition
it would not be fair so no these people
are not gluttons or glutens that's so
funny that spellcheck thing will get you
every time down on Society and it's not
even proper usually word glutton by the
way in this sentence but you know no
they're not gluttons they're not
gluttons at all they're just people that
have outperformed you that's all now
that here's the neat thing all of you
listening can decide at this moment to
change your performance level you can
decide to change your character you can
decide to change your vision you can
decide to change the level of education
you have by going and getting some more
it's so available information and
knowledge is so available in a in a
digital age that it's unbelievable
you can decide today starting right now
ready set go to be different tomorrow
and impact your tomorrow and you're
going to reap what you sow you're going
to grow in the in
in the fertile ground that is called
your life what you plant are some things
out there unfair do sometimes we get
betrayed or sometimes we get beat up
yeah that's true and if you don't want
to listen to this show I'm perfectly
good with that but don't you dare attack
these millionaires who have paid their
lives who have worked and worked and
saved and been frugal and good and kind
people every one of them that I talked
to and don't you dare attack that way of
life and expect me to do anything but
take their back this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you